welcome to this video playing a super
Sascha am super russia mark Becca which
I prefer to play three plus three or
four plus two we are be my guest but not
in the SSC Auto pairing okay we have an
end the selenium reverses so you know of
course the white sea voyage five a three
is an interesting sideline preventing
any Bishop before I came maybe I can get
in a set up here with E for a good
center you know this should be slightly
better for a while at least nothing
nothing spectacular but but okay um okay
I guess d5 I can take here and play
ninety FOIAs should be three maybe so
that after c5 and the capture I am no no
but he's giving up the pawn anyway it
was just a pawn blunder basically okay
um before there is maybe c5 yeah anyway
need to do that don't really have a good
piece move to come on it's got some
activity with Bishop f6 here probably
rook c1 maybe to get out of the diagonal
directly
Bishop f6 I can also consider to take on
d6 95 he can play maybe the black has
some some play on the dark squares
nothing I particularly believe in but
it's not it's not totally off yeah this
is this is what I of course expected but
I wonder if I can go for B c6 and give
up the exchange M might be three Queen D
one night XC one Quincy one that's not
enough it's not enough probably and if I
move the rook of course I need to be
aware of Bishop f6 coming okay probably
this one
and maybe something like a wookie aid
putting pressure on your form and then
would I then go Kessler I guess there is
nothing really nothing better really and
if I still have the b-pawn I can't take
what the night gem but okay this is this
is fine anyway now he needs to know it
needs to take twice on c3 anti-frog 95
is a very substantial threat that he
cannot ignore
and now taking I guess okay um the
question is though should I take on a
four for technical reasons or should I
should I keep the bishop zone yeah I
guess I should I guess got to karate too
no it's still probably right to keep
them on keep the bishop I'm against the
night I mean I have bishop c6 also it it
wasn't a so clear-cut because um the
capture and b6 directly also was rather
attractive
no I'm not sure what he's doing with the
fire I mean 25 Cunha 55 93 would be a
fork but as also bishop before at the
right moment being a problem now
okay let's play let's keep it to keep it
very simple trying to get to a good root
end game Jack and I'm behind the porn
it's not that's not the only thing my
king is is quickly approaching yeah that
I need to move the King directly I can
go all the way to e5 which is probably
right
King f6 down okay I'll start with this
move making sure that his rook is really
tight to be aid okay rook could be six
is one possibility but I can I can also
start with this
he wants to whom I understand you he
wants to after age five takes King takes
he wants to give the check on a fade
time morning that's still very good for
me I don't I don't really need to worry
about that look if it I can take a form
threatening b8 still so he cannot take
f2 and then I am mark much they have
porn I can always play a for him and if
he attacks that yeah like groupie g8 I
have Brooke it would be too
I'm basically just pushing the F poor
now check
mm-hmm this was probably not very
precise shouldn't have given up this
pawn check
black resigns hmm yeah I've had after
I've had some something better for sure
not quite sure exactly why is resigning
I mean it's it's probably still winning
I understand that but why exactly resign
now I shall go here for example I'm not
quite sure how I win something like this
you know let's have this check so I
don't know Jess this chicks how do I win
this check check check
no I can't I can take here but it does
not does not help me a lot
can I go rook h1 to h2 check my ass a
ton of chicks
maybe I'm it's a bad idea to take the
pawn it is a bad idea to take the pawn
yes check I'll go here maybe check
there's no way forward
I don't see when yeah don't I don't know
how do I win this it was it was a bit
just bad technical play him who can
harness winning this is winning and now
this is winning them as just the f-pawn
wins the game now I get it all the way
to f7 it needs to go back until here why
this winning easily I can go here and
then just take all the pawns yeah it was
it wasn't precise really what I did
again Luke f1 is winning and here I miss
stroke everyone all the time check
oh yeah tricky tricky the same game okay
I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching